yeah this morning we're having our puja
ceremony which is really the beginning
of the expedition the Sherpa won't climb
until they've had the blessing from the
Lama he'll do prayers for two or three
hours he'll read the scripture will burn
juniper and that will bless all the
members of the expedition and safeguard
us as we're climbing the mountain its
traditional for team members to bring
something to the puja to be blessed
typically crampons and ice axe maybe a
helmet before the trip our Sherpa team
get together look at the Tibetan
calendar and figure out an auspicious
day when we're gonna do something
dangerous like climbing Mount Everest
and we're gonna put ourselves on this
sacred mountain they have a lama come up
from bangla say the prayer flags and the
mast go up at a certain point and
everything goes in its correct sequence
but as you're sitting there through this
long ceremony it's impossible to forget
why we're doing this there's a little
bit of a heavy side to it but then at
the end it's a celebration during the
the ceremony
tears are a lot of throwing rice the
Samba comes out everybody grabs a big
handful of it it's thrown up in the air
and then it gets smeared all over
everybody space
it's beautiful and the prayer flags
flapping sending the prayers off to the
gods that's the intention